Grand Theft Auto might be making bucket
loads of money but parent company take
two is still so me that game development
in general is getting more expensive and
risky take tues veo Strauss Zelnick has
said that there is a significant risk
profile to consider in the business of
game development he told Bloomberg that
from our point of view it embeds the
winners even further it actually creates
a barrier to entry in our business
Melnyk added that it creates an issue
since the developer quotes cannot get in
not without having a couple hundred high
quality engineers and artists loads of
capital and lots of money to market to
title the games industry may be a tricky
place to succeed for some developers but
it's easy to say that the company
creating GTA doesn't fall into that
bracket GTA 5 has now shipped more than
45 million copies worldwide and we are
not even expecting that PC release for
another month let me know down in the
comments if you reckon the barrier of
entry in game development is too high
and why or why not we've got all your
latest tickets on site so be sure to
stay tuned to games but